they called the guy he's like yeah I'm
trying to figure out about the Russian
dope and he's like oh yeah that's me I
do it yep I dope all the Russian
athletes
but some of those those guys didn't know
like I will tell you I mean that is a
very sophisticated world I I don't know
if anybody's failed more drug tests than
me but the other side is I don't know if
anybody's gotten away with more drugs
than me right I mean they got me over
like seven substances but I was on at
least 17 like those tests yeah those
tests aren't all that good well they go
around and pray God we're so good it's
like you take it from me you got a lot
of flaws guys but I'll share this with
you Chris yes
one word what they're saying to you is
it's very sophisticated and those guys
aren't all that sharp and you know they
are the government coming in you take
this you know just like calisthenics
okay start doing your jumping jacks
here's a handful swallow it with one
hand shoot this with the other hand I
mean those athletes really weren't they
weren't in the know can can you tell us
some of the ways that people cheat drug
tests without throwing anybody under the
bus oh yeah you were that you said you
were on 17 of them and they only caught
you for seven yes secret well besides I
don't want to say well it's changed over
time like like moreover yeah here would
be a great question I think this is the
one that you're you're asking me how are
guys getting away with it now yeah and
right when USANA stepped in I mean we
had Champions who the day who saw the
steps in they have never won another
fight multiple Champions that had never
won another fight you got the Incredible
Shrinking Man Who Saw the steps in all
205 Pounders are now 185 Pounders it was
very obvious I'm just sharing with you
that now it's coming back and you're
starting to see it and I was very
curious and I called some guys that were
were experts and Masters in cheating you
just got I gotta know how are they doing
it and one guy tell me he said well the
rumor is and he said but I don't believe
it he said the rumor is that they're
micro dosing where they just take this
little tiny bit and they just take it
every day and it either doesn't show up
on the test because it's so small or its
thresholds you're within the limits and
he said but I don't personally believe
that this is what everybody's telling me
and we can take one look and know who's
Who's Cheating and who's not to try to
get those guys to talk or try to explain
it I mean it's it's it's a very
competitive
it's a real Competitive Edge if you told
one guy even if it was your best retail
one guy then he tells a guy he tells you
and all of a sudden you don't have that
Advantage anymore but there there is a
number of ways to get away with it where
I'm more concerned is kind of like
you're saying with the Russians which is
I don't believe that they knew that they
were cheating I don't believe that the
athletes knew they were doing something
like that and there is examples where
where trainers or coaches can get it
into uh their athletes without the
athletes sure through their drinks
you've heard of through their food
you've heard of but they can also do it
with topical creams and and things like
this and I mean we've got two gyms in
this sport where every one of them not
most of them not 90 100 of their guys
from both of those gyms are in Gross
violation but they get away with it and
I always wonder okay is it do they have
real good Secrets or is somebody at a
different level
administering this and I don't know the
answer to that and that would be
speculative and that would be very uh
very dirty what I'm suggesting right now
wouldn't they get caught you would think
if they were if they were you would
think but look at them Russians didn't
until they did yeah
and that's wild yeah
and that's a big one that I just said
out there I'll just I'll just share for
you
there were two gems it's 100 of the time
you look at it my God you look at all
the corner and the corner men are Juiced
out of their minds go okay you guys all
you need is really good at keeping your
mouth shut because most Fighters aren't
you could telephone Telegraph or tell a
fighter the word's gonna get out these
guys can either keep a secret or they
don't know that it's happening which is
possible
it is possible I think Secret's pretty
hard to keep yeah yeah this happened in
uh with a Turkish wrestler in 2012 and
the guy made the Olympic team and he
denied that he was cheating when usada
caught him just like everybody does but
there was something different about his
denial people go yeah that's right
that's right but where the guy goes
there's something different I I believe
him that he doesn't know so they tested
the food and they tested the drink and
they finally looked into it and he had a
trainer and the trainer used to massage
him at the end of the night oh your
shoulder all and that's it was on his
hand and he would put it in through a
substance called uh uh DMSO and DMO so
is topical it used to be for
veterinarian use only but it'll take
anything on this and it'll bring it
inside right into your veins so we would
have the testosterone and he'd have the
EPO and he'd have it mixed with the EPL
let me rub your shoulder at all and
every day he would do that and he juice
this athlete he took him from number
five in the country to number one in the
world but they caught him they got hit
they pulled his Olympic birth they found
out the trainer did it they let him go
to the Olympics after all
I'm just sharing with you that as wild
and crazy of a story as it is for me to
even suggest that somebody could be
dosing an entire team like yes 100 it's
possible yeah and has happened I mean in
back in your day you probably fought a
lot of people on juice yes definitely
and uh
[__] yeah it does make a difference oh
yeah it was part of it I mean that was
very easy to beat back then because that
you knew when the test was going to be
it wasn't a drug test it was an IQ test
at that point
um but you know now with what they do
with us yeah now it's now it's it's much
tougher they can come and they can come
often uh but Bellator does not have
usada is that right yep that's right
that's right and your last fight was uh
in Bellator against Tito Ortiz I thought
Machida was my last fight yeah I
followed Tito
yeah but my last one was uh gosh and it
feels like yesterday but it was years uh
2019 with Machida okay yeah my mistake
um now at the time when you went over to
Bellator you were in the UFC still had
fights remaining on your contract and
somehow pulled off what seemingly nobody
else has you got out of your UFC
contract and into Bellator yes how did
that happen well and so it wasn't over
the Plex I I've gotten a lot of credit
for that and I was even able to announce
for both and people like oh my God
chill's got it figured out but there was
no secret recipe it was just hey Dana
can I do this hey Coker are you good
with this and it just it just happened
to work out but I don't know how badly
it was an interesting spot where where
Dana was kind of pulling back on some
older guys and Coker was going no those
guys are still fun and they've got some
life in them it's kind of a conflict
between the two uh organizations so
um
yeah I think it just timing wise it
worked out for me and uh you know it
doesn't it doesn't hurt when people like
you I mean that doesn't hurt to have a
friend on the other end of the phone but
right we were able to work that out uh
pretty quickly
yeah pretty quickly allowed for a good
opportunity
that's Epic
um with uh I think that you had that you
saw the thing going on too which would
certainly played into it definitely yeah
I just I just ran that out I had to deal
with a suspension I think is what you're
talking about but I had just ran that
out and that was a tough one I mean that
was a real tough one for me I go before
this Commission in Nevada and they bring
in an expert witness and the expert
wouldn't and I had pled guilty I went in
there and said I'm not going to put up a
defense go ahead and punish me but it
was hard because I was being accused of
legal appropriate medication and they
brought in an expert who comes in and
says the word steroid six times and so
we kind of argue and go hey wait a
minute we're not here first to and the
commission didn't understand the
difference and we even had a
commissioner say are you putting up a
defense yes if you charge us a bank
robbery or murder we're going to defend
that too we're not here for steroids
these are medications trt that's right
trt was one of them
um sure but but they actually banned trt
so then there was like clomiphene and
HCG which is what you have to do if you
come off of T4 trt was completely
appropriate and they they had changed
the rules so we kind of go okay fine
we're going to fall down on this but
you're saying that we're in violation of
something called water and I said this
to the room I said you're a room of
experts let me make this real simple
tell me what city wat is in and I'll sit
down and I won't say that we're going by
water rules tell me what city they're in
I go let me make it easier you tell me
what state what is and you're the expert
that's about to punish me tell me what
Statewide is in I'll sit down and I'll
I'll take it on you got my final offer
tell me what country water's from and to
this day they haven't answered that
question and I do bring that up it's
very relevant you tell me we're going to
go off of a set of rules from an
organization that nobody even knows what
country they're in we don't they don't
have a phone number I can't call see
who's in charge but I'm supposed to know
what their rules are that's a bunch of
crap and they said yes it's incumbent on
you so I'm the lowest form of society
there is I'm a cage fighter I'm right
down there with a prostitute and the guy
that celebrates
you're the government you're the
government and you can't tell me what
city later country therein but I'm
supposed to know their rules that's not
right and they said well don't you know
that what you took is a performance
enhancer I said guys let me be very
clear I would never take anything if I
didn't have a reasonable expectation
that it would enhance my performance I'm
not looking to go down I'm only taking
things that enhance it performance
enhancing those are positive words right
those aren't negatives and then this guy
comes in he talks about steroids it's
like I'm not here for steroids now I'm
here for legal medications not sterile
but it was I was jammed up and they
didn't understand the difference it's a
really interesting point that you make
because I've
thought that like
any athlete that you know for my
entertainment purposes I would like
their performance to be enhanced like
please enhance my
very weird they acted like that was bad
it's like do you guys know what the FDA
is I mean the first thing that you have
to prove the FDA is this is make
somebody better what do you mean
performance I mean dancing is a bad how
exciting was Jose Canseco Mark McGuire
that's the only time I watched baseball
when they're smashing 600 foot dollars
Mark McGuire and he credited something
he said and he credited something said
he got it at GNC and I was in my car I
was 17. I was in my car I was down to
GNC so goddamn fast they were all sold
out it was called a decade I can't think
of what it was now but yeah he said this
is what I'm taking and you couldn't find
it it was off the shelves but it was a
lie turned out to be growth hormone he
should have just told us yeah it's the
same thing with Lance Armstrong's like
Lance just tell us these are helpful
things you're doing something really
amazing here don't lie about it yeah
John Cena rocker the liver King who we
saw a week ago it's like guys stop lying
these are good if you figured something
out tell us maybe we could do it yeah
right you know athletes have given it a
bad name I don't suggest that athletes
do it to cheat like I did but I'm just
talking about for every every day
citizens you know you had Stallone and
uh Schwarzenegger and Suzanne Summers
all came out 20 years ago and said
estrogen testosterone growth hormone
these are wonderful things and then you
get guys like in Lance Armstrong they're
afraid to tell Oprah like he's scared of
Oprah just say I took some growth or I
never understood that side of it the
rock lies about it to this day it's like
rock what are you doing man tell people
help people right it's like watching
Terminator 2 without him doing steroids
you're like I wouldn't watch that
athletes have given it a bad rap
athletes have get but those guys aren't
athletes they're humans and they're
citizens and they're living a better
life
because like uh you know TJ dilshaw uh
fought Cody garbrand one was on one was
off and it made a difference in their
careers so a good argument for it yeah I
think that it's fair yes yes they're
both doing it there's no excuses that's
right no it would level things out yeah
I came through it was kind of the face
of uh the testosterone era and it was
legal we were allowed to do testosterone
and it got really hard to regulate so
one day when they just pulled it out and
said you're done but I knew other guys
that were like me but they weren't
candid like me and said well it didn't
help me anyway and it was my hard work
it's like well but let me tell you the
other side it did help me It Made Me
Stronger it helped with my recovery it
made me better that's why I was doing it
but there was something I I don't know
guys were scared to say that they're
still scared to say that and athletes
have given testosterone and growth
ornament a very bad rap
show me a doctor that puts either one of
them down and that's an open challenge
find a doctor anywhere go online Dr Drew
is all about
amazing medication yeah right doctors
will tell you to be very careful to make
sure that you consult with an endic
chronologist and do it right use versus
abuse for sure I uh like have it on my
to-do list for the last like six years
to make an appointment with an
endocrinologist I just haven't gotten
around to it should I have yeah sounds
like a shot down yeah
48. yes 48 yeah time for me to start
yeah but they just have levels you know
you go into a blood draw and they can
show you but use versus abuse is very
tough with human beings a human being
hey you need to well
yeah right if what if they if they had a
pill that would cure alcoholism we'd
crush it up and smoke it
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
steamos butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude